most tavern now speaking hi I was hoping
you could tell me what state Springfield
is in session go when I get a hold of
you I'm gonna use your head for a bucket
and pick my house with your brain well
that escalated quickly
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that
proves you can turn watching Netflix
reruns into a job and while reruns are
the only way to enjoy most of our
favorite shows from the 90s unless you
know someone's eager for a quick cash
grab based on brand awareness there's
one show that is hung on The Simpsons
came out in a simpler time time when
cell phones were the size of bricks and
the word fleek hadn't earned itself a
place in the dictionary speaking of the
dictionary though homers catchphrase of
dough was actually added a few years ago
and it's where the common usage of the
word Mac comes from crazy right from the
kwik-e-mart the prototype of internet
trolls The Simpsons is truly a cultural
icon and yet after nearly three decades
one huge mystery about the series
remains unanswered where do the Simpsons
live we all know they live in
Springfield that part's obvious but the
state has always been a question and
this isn't by accident the show has
taunted viewers for years by giving
information that would make it virtually
impossible for anyone to determine
exactly where Springfield is notice
though that I said virtually impossible
because after sifting through the
evidence there is more than enough proof
to deduce where the Simpsons actually
reside today we're closing the books on
one of prime times longest-running
riddles now hold on to your comment hand
all you walking Simpsons encyclopedias
I'm sure you're just waiting to point
out that there are tons of jokes and
references in the Simpsons that
contradict each other
what about that time in the Simpsons
movie for instance when Flanders says
that the four states that border
Springfield are Ohio Nevada Maine and
Kentucky no such state does or ever
could exist well stupid sexy Flanders
that's a fair point but here's the thing
the running jokes about where
Springfield is mostly there to throw off
would-be theorists so if we want to
determine where Springfield really is we
need to look for evidence that's given
when the show isn't joking about the
impossibility of its location reference
also goes to episodes that are older
both because they're less likely to
present Springfield as a place that
couldn't exist and because many die-hard
Simpsons fans consider episodes after
season 9 to be non canonical because the
show changed executive producers got all
that good
because we have a mystery to solve since
the Simpsons take so much pride and
never revealing its big mystery our best
tactic to prove where Springfield is is
to work backwards and eliminate where it
isn't 50 states is a lot to cover so
let's knock out a bunch right off the
bat in season 5 Bart wins a call-in
contest at Springfield's local radio
station and gets to choose between a
grand prize of $10,000 or an elephant
Bart picks the elephant high jinks
ensues and Homer gets stuck in the La
Brea Tar Pits so what's this have to do
with Springfield's location well the
radio station Bart calls is named kbbl
and it's referenced in a number of other
Simpsons episodes from the first several
seasons so we can say that it is indeed
a permanent fixture in Springfield and
not just someone off joke a random
writer came up with why does this matter
well in the early 1920s the Federal
Communications Commission established a
system for radio station call letters
all states east of the Mississippi River
would have call letters that started
with W like NBC's New York radio station
WNYC and stations west of the mighty
Mississip would start with the letter K
Springfield's kbbl thus could not be in
any of the 26 states that are completely
east of the Mississippi River Minnesota
and Louisiana are the exceptions with
stations that start with both K and W so
they'll stay for now but still there
goes half the country in one fell swoop
how has no one figure this out yet
seriously people do your research then
again maybe I've spoken too soon because
from here gives a lot trickier we get
some good geographical clues from the
season 7 episode Bart on the road Bart
manages to get a fake ID rent a car for
spring break and ends up getting himself
and his friends stranded in Knoxville
Tennessee on the road from Springfield
to Knoxville the group drives through
Branson Missouri stopping to listen to
the smooth crooning of Andy Williams if
you're wondering who Andy Williams is
don't worry people watching that episode
at the time it was aired probably didn't
know who Andy Williams was such a random
old reference anyway let's take a look
at the map Branson is in the southwest
corner of Missouri and Knoxville is in
eastern Tennessee Bart would have had to
take a pretty major detour to get to
Branson if their point of origin was in
Louisiana Arkansas or Texas
so we can eliminate all of those and
unless the rental car is one of those
duck boats that goes from water to land
they drive into Tennessee from Hawaii
no big surprise Hawaii is off the table
in this
episode we see a map of all the nuclear
reactors in the United States above
homers workstations when the camera
zooms in we can see California Nevada
and Utah completely and none of their
reactors are labeled Springfield another
three states bite the dust now we need
to think about the topography of
Springfield
we know that Springfield has mountains
from episodes like mountain of madness
mr. plow and king of the hill not to be
confused with this one damn it Bobby
hungry
I swear my new year's resolution is to
stop doing impressions in the Simpsons
episode king of the hill Homer gets in
shape and is hired by a protein bar
company to climb the murder horn the
tallest mountain in Springfield in one
scene we see Homer sucking on oxygen
tanks witches guides packed to prevent
altitude sickness
according to WebMD altitude sickness is
extremely rare below 8,000 feet above
sea level Minnesota Iowa Missouri North
Dakota South Dakota Nebraska Kansas and
Oklahoma all have highest points that
are shorter than that 8,000 foot mark
2.4 kilometer so they're all out that
means we're down to our final 9 Alaska
Washington Oregon Idaho Montana Wyoming
Colorado New Mexico and Arizona this
isn't a surprise but it's definitely not
Alaska in the Simpsons movie the entire
family uproots from Springfield and
moves to Alaska
we even see them entering the state for
the first time so Alaska is out we've
got a couple of clues that help us
eliminate some southwestern states as
well the season 5 episode Boy Scouts in
the hood clearly I live the thug life
myself
Bart and his jr. camper troupe get lost
when they go whitewater rafting
Homer tries navigate using a map of
krustyburger locations and says the
following
hey there's a New Mexico and in the
process knocks the state out of the
running now let's jump ahead to seasons
two season sevens king-size Homer in it
Homer gets to his desk at 8:58 in the
morning marking that it's the first time
he's ever been early for work quote chip
roll of daylight savings days this
eliminates Arizona because it's the only
state in the lower 48 that doesn't
observe daylight savings time geez
Arizona way to be different at least
it's simpler than Australia's daylight
savings time system I mean seriously
did you know about this they have
half-hour time zones and the continent
is divided into how does this make any
sense anyway another big Geographic clue
is Springfield's proximity to water
besides the fact that one of
Springfield's odd residence is a
grizzled old sea captain we see in
numerous episodes that Springfield is
near the ocean Homer and Marge take a
romantic walk on the beach in and Maggie
makes three from season six Bart and
Lisa track down Krusty the Klown
disguised as a longshoreman and Bart the
Fink and Marge and Homer reunite and
declare themselves soul mates at a
lighthouse in lva hey elviejo
lva hey mysterioso didn't West row Homer
yeah that's an episode that appeared in
season 8 well we don't have a solid
indication that Springfield is a beach
town necessarily it's safe to say that
it must be a short distance from the
coast as a result all remaining
landlocked states are out sayonara to
Idaho Montana Colorado and Wyoming and
that my friends leaves us with to
Washington State and Oregon these two
states are really similar their
geography climate topography and
demographics are pretty close to
identical but there's an incredibly
minor detail that helps us eliminate
Springfield from one of them and it's so
small that I can guarantee that even the
most hardcore of Simpsons aficionados
might have missed it which one is it
place your bets in the comments now and
then let me know if you won ready in the
season 7 episode much of puh about
nothing a bear wanders into Springfield
leaving an angry mob to demand
protection from the Bears mayor Quimby
establishes a bear patrol and when Homer
next opens his paycheck he's outraged to
see a five dollar tax for this new
government service but if we zoom in on
that paycheck on the left side three
rows down that paycheck indicates that
ten dollars and forty-five cents were
withheld by state tax why does this
matter because there are nine states in
the US with no state-level income tax
Alaska Florida Nevada New Hampshire
South Dakota Tennessee Texas Wyoming and
last but not least
Washington State i Caramba we have
ourselves a winner The Simpsons home
town is Springfield Oregon now
admittedly no single small town could
have every single feature that the
Simpsons have ascribed to the fictional
Springfield over the years but
geographically and based on Clues hidden
throughout the series Oregon is indeed
the best fit with a little bit of
everything
coastline forests deserts tall mountains
and gorges man I'm starting to feel like
the Oregon Board of tourism Oregon more
than just trail but you're still having
a cow over the results there's one more
piece of evidence to consider and it
comes from the creator of the series
himself Matt graining some diehard
Simpsons fans might remember that before
the Simpsons was its own show it was a
series of short cartoons on The Tracey
Ullman Show Matt grading was a
cartoonist whose most popular cartoon at
the time life in hell had caught the
attention of the makers of that show who
then asked him to pitch cartoons for the
series raining wanted to make sure that
he would retain all ownership over life
in hell so he pitched a cartoon to The
Tracey Ullman Show on the fly as he
improved his way through this pitch he
named the patriarch after his own father
Homer and he said that the family would
live on Evergreen Terrace the same
street that he grew up on as a child
want to guess where Matt graining is
from yep Portland Oregon in an interview
with Smithsonian magazine graining said
that he initially wanted to name each
character after street from Portland and
for a while he succeeded turning
Portland's Flanders Street Lovejoy
Street and Quimby streets into recurring
characters on the series and the
real-life Springfield Oregon is just a
short trip south on Interstate five from
Portland even though the Simpsons
Springfield is meant to be an anonymous
all-american city it's been set in
Oregon from the very first pitch but hey
that's just a theory of film theory and
cut so that's pretty awesome but
admittedly I'm not the first Simpsons
theorists out there in fact did you know
that a lot of the Simpsons writing team
have advanced degrees in math and
physics it's true
one author Simon Singh actually tracked
all the mathematical references in the
show to uncover the surprising truth
that the Simpsons
loli introduces number theory into the
minds of its viewers no joke and if
you're interested it's worth mentioning
that the book is available to download
on audible.com audible has been a
regular sponsor for us this video
included and for good reason it's a
service I believe in for instance I
myself didn't have time to read simon's
book but I did have time to listen to it
in the car chapter by chapter driving
between meetings and it was fantastic I
highly recommend you check it out but I
wouldn't know that without the service
and currently listening to the Gospel
according to The Simpsons which looks at
how the Simpsons treat religion it's
pretty cool stuff and audible makes
quote-unquote reading more books much
more possible in my everyday life and if
you want something other than deep
analysis of cartoons I don't know why
you would but maybe you do for you
audible has over a hundred and eighty
thousand books available to download and
listen to and if you want to check it
out you can have a 30 day free trial by
going to audible.com/veritasium and in
turn support our ability to do more
videos for you and you do that by simply
getting your 30 day free trial by going
to audible.com
that's audible.com slash
fi lm t now if you'll excuse me I need
to find some books about inception maybe
someone out there knows what that movie
was all about